- [Voiceover] Hey grammarians,
we've talked about prepositions of time
and we've talked about
prepositions of space
and I couldn't come up
with a cute name for these
because the following five prepositions
are examples of what we
would call prepositions
that have connotations for
neither time nor space.
Some of them do have time connotations
and some of them do have
physical connotations
and what we're going to
talk about today, however,
are the uses of these
words, these prepositions,
that don't have anything
to do with time or space,
they just have, they
encode other relationships.
Let's get to it, I'll
show you what I mean.
When we say about it can mean
you're talking about a specific subject.
So I could say to you,
"Tell me about yourself!"
The word by can be used to
denote agency or doing this.
You'll see what I mean by that.
I mean we can figure out who
is responsible for something
with the use of the word by.
The book was written by Sudhir.
So who did the thing?
Sudhir did the thing,
he's the person with
agency, he's the doer.
The word for denotes use.
So if you were to ask me, for example,
"David what's a wood chipper used to do?"
I would say, "It's for chipping wood,
"for turning wood into chips,
it's purpose is chipping."
Of has this connotation of belonging
or being part of a place.
So we can talk about the great
green dragon of Inverness.
Inverness is a place, it's in Scotland.
Are there dragons there?
I don't know, I've never been.
And with means together or part of.
There goes that snail
with the painted shell
which indicates that
the snail and the shell
are part and parcel, they're together.
So yeah, so these prepositions can be used
for all sorts of things.
I understand this can be confusing.
Prepositions are probably
the most complicated part of English
and the problem is you
just need to memorize them.
But the good thing is that
there aren't that many
because, as I've said before,
prepositions are a closed
group, we don't mint new ones.
So you don't have to be
constantly trying to collect
more ones, or pick them up,
or figure them out.
You have a limited set
that you need to master
and the way to do that is to read,
and listen, and talk a lot.
You can do that, you can
learn anything, David out.